over 70 countries in the world have
anti-homosexuality laws
now this means that in some countries
loving someone of the same sex could
either land you in prison
or even cost you your life now
in kenya the lgbq community has
constantly pushed against repressive
laws that
some have termed relics of colonial
times
however in 2018 the gay and human rights
groups had a big
win when their high court outlawed anal
exams now these are some intrusive
medical tests that would be carried out
when someone was suspected to be gay
following that when activists partnered
together to repeal a law that punishes
same-sex relations in kenya with up to
14 years
so how does one live in a society that
barely tolerates them
on the show today we have brian masharia
who's a communications
officer at the gay and lesbian coalition
in kenya
brian welcome so much to the show
thank you very much how was it like
growing up
as a gay person in kenya people who
identify as
lesbian gay bisexual transgender
queer and non-binary um experience
a multitude of you know challenges in
different spheres
there is what is you know real id you
know
identity where a person legitimately and
publicly identifies as
a member of the lgbtq community and
there are those who are perceived
to be lgbtq for me to be members of the
lgbtq community
a that be it from engaging in media
representation
and media correspondence such as this or
just people who
you know you walk a certain way you talk
a certain way you have
physical gestures and gender expressions
that do not conform
or are kind of in conflict with the body
that you have so say you
you have a you're a ma you look like a
man with beards and yet you have a
feminine justice
then people will very automatically
um assume um that you are a member of
the lgbtq community and
therefore immediately resort to violence
and you know stigma and discrimination
how was it for you to come out to your
parents
to your schoolmates i was forced i was
supposed to just
sit somewhere in the corner and i'm just
like yeah brian you're gonna go
and tell the world um about how
colorfully gay and proudly gay you are
no that wasn't them because i hadn't
achieved that level of self-affirmation
at the time
i was still very unaware i didn't know
whether there was a lgbtq community in
kenya
i felt like i was the only one in the
world in kenya
so i was very you know conservative i
tried to keep this as
quiet as i could by my gender expression
is a completely different thing
something i have little control over so
because of that people quickly just
picked up
you know how different i was how that
how
my gender expression didn't conform to
the stereotypes of you know gender
expression
and so because of that i was a target
um and so any little thing i did
was constantly underscore me because it
could
stand out and around how old were you
when you noticed this that you were the
target
um it started about two years ago like
when i was 16
but that trigger when i was taking when
i was 16 years old
um but it quieted down over a couple of
months
and um for the better part of my 17
years
for the better part of when i was 17 i
was
very you know very very conservative
very
quiet trying not to engage with boys try
not to attract any unnecessary attention
until something another trigger then
um when i was just about to get to my 18
18th birthday and that is when that was
the camera that was the stroke that
broke the camel's back
what happened well
uh so i was i was in the i i had a
i had a thing i had a relationship with
this uh
boy in high school um we write each
other a little more
communicating with each other you know
meeting today how's your day how you
doing like you know
things so one of the letters i
wrote fell into the wrong hands
it's like someone spotted me writing it
before i even
finished and though i didn't send it
i kept it just securely in a particular
place
a couple of people had spotted it and
they were they have followed it so
when i left and i went to do other
things this broke into my locker found a
letter
and yeah it became a thing because they
shared it with people they should be
people and the school
you know just a couple of hours people
restless over this
alleged love letter between two boys
and that caused uh called the attention
of that school administration
um and you know once it got to the
school administration
became a got suspended the following day
um and i always react when you came home
my my mother well my mother my
my father wasn't around at the time so
that wasn't an issue um
so i had to deal with my mother and my
elder brother
so when i went home and i told my mother
to suspend it
obviously i could tell the tension
because i grew up very strict
background expectations of success
and you know steadiness and you know
just
you know being an exemplary child was so
high
so when anything that shook those
expectations it was problematic for my
mom so
um she did not take it very well she
asked me to go stay with my grandmother
because she didn't feel comfortable
with me staying in the house by myself
during the day
um when when she finally got comfortable
with having me around
um she called cops he stayed some arrest
yes she says policing in casual where in
the
um got rested
we had a help in the house and my
grandmother's house was also okay
and he was also arrested
because my parents perceived that she
was the one who
indoctrinated me into homosexuality
which was completely different
which was completely because they got
the police station um
and yeah so your parents were okay with
having
a help who was homosexual but not having
their son
as a homosexual person for some reason
yeah because
their help was doing a lot of work in
the house but they they were okay with
having him around but
they were not okay with him uh teaching
me how to be homosexual because that is
what they thought
they thought i'm only gay because i
learned it from the health and i'm like
no like it's been it's been here for
like two years and i have been
gay my entire life could you tell us a
little more about this
petition or about the laws specifically
um so kenya like many other countries
that have been colonized by the british
inherited a set of laws
that criminalize kind of knowledge
against the order of nature which
in essence is uh punishing any
type of unnatural sex um any sex that is
not leading to procreation is considered
unnatural and that's
punishable by up to 14 years according
to the laws of kenya
we're trying to to make it clear to the
kenyan population that
these are laws that apply to all kenyans
anyone who identifies as kenyan in
kenyan soil
can be prosecuted based on these
sections of the penal code however
that is not the case um the case that we
see right now
is these laws have been used um
incessantly
incessantly to oppress and violate the
human rights of people who identify as
lgbtq
in kenya as the lgbq community in kenya
continues to push for
change what do some canyons think of
these laws let's take a listen
such a fundamental decision should not
just be left for the
high court of kenya or for our judicial
system to decide
now i believe we are having a referendum
very soon
and if so be it then i
feel this should be a fundamental
question in the plebiscite
now brian the next question is related
to what he says
do ordinary people even know about this
law
we feel that um there is a little bit of
you know misinformation
um from the general public um our
political elites
um have made enormous efforts to create
a perception that
you know these laws exist and they are
only
uh they only exist to punish um
unnatural sex they only exist to punish
identities that are not straight
now an interesting report by amnesty
group
says that women to women marriages have
been documented in over 40
ethnic groups in africa that's including
nigeria
kenya south sudan but even with a long
cultural
background many families still have a
problem with homosexuality
let's take a look at this street by june
eric odory a
uk activist with nigerian roots she
openly identifies as a black
lesbian woman and this is how her mother
reacts to her june
in muslim countries they kill people for
being a lesbian
it just means you can't find a mind to
love you
now the mother continues to write i will
completely disown you and sue you
until you stop using the the name eric
odori
now let's take a listen to what people
in nairobi are saying would they disown
their families if they came out to them
as homosexual persons i will discern him
him or her i don't care i don't care
what you say i don't care who you are
don't give you my brother i would disown
my family member if they came out
to me how come on are this
how come on is this rhetoric indeed a
lot of parents
have this sentiment but this is a
sentiment that is
uh stemming from a place of
misinformation it is a sentiment that is
coming from a place of
fear it is timing it is it is a
sentiment that is stemming from a place
of
uncertainty and the fear of the unknowns
thank you very much brian for joining us
and shedding light on this significant
repeal in kenya now if you would like to
watch this video or
more like this that we have on the show
make sure you subscribe and
hit the notification button below that
way you will know
what's up on what happened next till
next time
goodbye
you